the field of Republican candidates in the 2024
presidential race is growing former New Jersey
governor that's Chris Christie former vice
president Mike Pence and North Dakota governor
Doug Byrne burgum are all announcing their runs
Caitlin Huey Burns is in Washington keeping track
of all the candidates who are getting in Caitlin
good morning to you good morning to you Gail well
Chris Christie will make it official tonight with
a Town Hall in New Hampshire remember Christie was
once a trump Ally and advisor but now he's trying
to set himself apart from the rest of the field as
one of the toughest Trump critics in the race he
liked himself more than he liked to make former
New Jersey Governor Chris Christie once used his
Street Fighter brand to defend Donald Trump I am
proud to be here to endorse Donald Trump for
president of the United States now he's hoping
to bring him down I got off the train when he
stood up in the west wing of the White House
behind the seal the president and told us the
election was stolen Christie is testing whether
there are enough Republicans willing to get off
that train with him focusing his second run for
the presidency on New Hampshire's independent
voters but he joins an already crowded field
of candidates which may benefit Trump the answer
Iowa is strong Conservative Republican leadership
former vice president Mike Pence filed his
paperwork for president and will launch his
campaign tomorrow in Iowa where he hopes to court
Evangelical voters away from his former boss and
North Dakota Republican Governor Doug burgum will
also join The Fray on Wednesday anger yelling
infighting that's not going to cut it anymore but
one GOP politician is making news for not jumping
into the race New Hampshire Governor Kristen
Nunu says he can be more effective from the
outside I think more folks within the Republican
Party have to have that kind of voice and making
sure that this is about the Republican
party not just about the former president
now the next challenge for all of these candidates
is meeting the debate requirements for that first
crucial debate coming in August and among the
criteria is a pledge to support the eventual
nominee now notably Donald Trump hasn't
said whether he'll sign such a pledge and
actually he's hinted at skipping that debate
altogether Nate we shall see Caitlin thank you